on the set of my very first motion
picture ever it's a movie called Mac and
Me and I want to introduce you to
him Mac and Me was a blatant ripoff of
ET the 1982 hit directed by Steven
Spielberg the alien becomes known as Mac
presumably named after the Big Mac
McDonald's signature menu item according
to thrillist the film's producer RJ
Lewis claims similarities to the Big Mac
are a complete coincidence which is very
difficult to believe because of the
Relentless product placement throughout
the entire rest of the movie the people
involved claimed that the movie was not
directly funded by McDonald's it was
part of a vision to sell movie products
through the McDonald's brand and it may
have been funded by McDonald's supplier
Golden State food thrill states that
Lewis had worked on McDonald's campaigns
in the past and remained close with
Ronald McDonald House charities in other
words Ronald himself was lewis' Inn to
acquire the rights to use the McDonald's
brand